hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to
especially when you shouldn't have to my
god is today's movie bad it is one of
the worst Christmas flicks you could
possibly see it's a wonderful little
piece of shit Bob called Christmas with
the cracks
this is based on the John Grisham novel
yes that John Grisham he was so good at
making white people afraid of the
justice system that I guess he decided
to make white people afraid of Christmas
too
he succeeded but in a way he probably
didn't intend it's mind-blowing how
little this movie tries how tired the
writing is how it doesn't attempt in any
way to give us anything new the jokes
are years old the acting is like
something out the 50s it's message is
beyond half-assed and lazy
it's just friggin horrendous it's so bad
I wish I could give this review as
little effort as possible wish did
somebody say wish no no no I'm not doing
that Santa Christ no I am NOT doing to
find this review with any kind of effort
whatsoever well we put these costumes on
for no reason
Carrie Yuletide hammer you know wait
disciples get back here you pointy-eared
Russia's Critic what's going on this
movie tries so little to be anything
interesting or good I wanted to vote as
little effort as possible to it like the
good old days you know before I had a
budget or a studio just talked in front
of a camera I didn't have to try as hard
things were easier and better than well
the segue you were going to put effort
into what it made that happen but since
you're not interested no cut it up no I
won't keep this weed to seat shit poor
delivery gave me very well then buy the
discontinuous powers that somehow killed
me in the cinema star crossover yet
brought me back yeah sorry about that
dick I send you to the past
oh this is just my folks place not just
your folks place your folks place in
2007 hey do you mean I can see it's
yummy holy shit what's going on here hey
you want to travel to the future for a
day really I get to see all the new
ideas Hollywood comes up with that's
right I know for you I'm in come with me
who's slightly overweight scam
hello shitty camera
hello shitty lights hello shitty movie
this is the cheapest possible review I
can give to you no budget no cutaways
just one asshole piece of shit talking
to another asshole piece of shit this is
Christmas with the Kranks
the movie opens with a convention center
doubling as an airport where two parents
played by Jamie Lee Curtis and Tim Ellen
are saying goodbye to their daughter
who's just off to join the Peace Corps
as we also say goodbye to the only bit
of human decency this film will offer us
I just need a couple things from chips
they stop by the store to pick up some
items or rather Curtis has her husband
go in to pick up some items didn't bring
the umbrella I need that stuff from
trips I didn't bring the umbrella well I
still need it should have done Santa
Claus for but he doesn't get the right
stuff so she sends him in again until he
gets it right did you talk to Rex
the butcher I didn't think of asking the
butcher where the chocolate was but I
will all right characters everybody but
Kardashian's - down to earth for you
well sit back and enjoy these charming
a-holes ideally thank you eat an
umbrella you know why I don't want what
are you stupid brother
you know there's slapstick and then
there's crap stick I much rather eat
crab stick rather than watch any of this
alright I don't have any visuals um home
wrong wrong grab sure fed up he goes to
the office to figure out how much they
spend on Christmas into year and just to
give you an idea of what kind of movie
were in for this is the kind of music
they play throughout the entire thing
yep at Einstein for baby score
accompanies the whole film it's like
having this music throughout the entire
review movie with you with you and
guarantee with you in doing the review
and you and your DVD reviewing see how
much money they spend every year ellen
has an idea good make sure you shut the
curtain so she must fix I'll be right
back for I want sex on the table a
common error as he explains that they
should cancel their Christmas party and
go on a cruise instead the most
luxurious ship in their fleet cayman
islands sparkling was that snorkeling or
chloroforming great that heavy dose of
that would be welcomed at nighttime well
we can still give our charitable
donations to Children's Hospital and and
of course the church no this is a total
boycott honey it's $600 it's a total
boycott yes as part of a complete
asshole package look there's even a part
we can sign up for Isis don't you just
sympathize with these people
she horribly agrees as she forgot we
have to put up with them throughout the
entire picture as Allen writes a
pointless letter saying he's not
participating Christmas to his
co-workers he says he's not angry or
bitter yet he's so angrily and bitterly
hands the letters out I am NOT angry and
I will not yell a bug no really I'm not
angry not even the slightest say what's
that Curtis also lets the ant from
Sabrina the Teenage Witch know and
immediately anger starts to spread we're
not going to do Christmas this year
how do you simply not do Christmas she's
not ordering Christmas cards either
don't you know Christmas is about not
embracing variety and shame those who do
we're taking a break one year off no
Christmas whatsoever I told you this
would happen if we let refugees in there
pluck is not especially happy we're not
buying a Christmas tree this year
sorry we had to go up on the price for
making less per tree than last year it's
not about the money even though you
clearly said that it is about the money
hello hello anybody home oh yeah yeah I
forgot I cut two random film clips a lot
more in the past got it goofy I'm glad
he slimed me knock it off okay maybe
some of the traditions of the past are a
little much but you know what it's still
great to be back in the good old days
are you gonna stop swearing people are
gonna find this charming the Boy Scouts
go and tell the head of the block played
by Dan Aykroyd about the crimes
abandoning Christmas Becker is at it
again
even big enjoying the randomly placed no
puddles the Sun didn't melt for some
reason but I gotta tell you a lot of the
neighbors are pretty upset you're trying
to make me feel guilty get off of it
you're just upset because my
home-improvement bumped in safes
solanell perfect time to put up frosty
but of course it doesn't stop there as
every house on the block apparently
hangs up some giant frosty decoration oh
come on you know what never has and
never will be a thing and the Krantz
refused to hang there's spreading more
misery to the easily offended still
working for the man huh thought they
would have made you a partner by now I
got to get to work I have a good one oh
man
wow that's some prime meat asshole right
there okay yesterday's asshole no no you
deserve the creme de la creme asshole
straight from the witch's vagina bah
humbug
good morning mr. Scrooge wal Marco said
I had to buy my own cheap perfume
so Santa Claus isn't coming this year
well at least our Starbucks cups are
still celebrating Christmas my first
world problem get a load of this
the neighbors actually line up outside
their house demanding frosty do any of
these people work we're here frosty oh
oh come on Lady Olive Oyl wouldn't
overreact this March they want frosty
well they can't have him give uncle wait
don't give them probably not giving into
a demand that would take seconds of no
effort is working out great in this
stress free Christmas that we apparently
wanted I am trapped here I am the one
dealing with this hi Juliet list of Mike
Myers approaching the house I said she
react last 200 that's FRA don't have any
actors um I only moved the camera
no no I'm keeping it still simple old
days um Mike Myers you may be a serial
killer but these people want you to hang
that snowman but they're dangerous
if only I could get you this afraid of
me Tommy Mike Myers it's Christmas town
you know the past is a lot more awkward
than I remember it
she tries driving away but the neighbors
who have literally sacrificed the art of
having a social life chase her down
you know crap stick is too good a word
for this how about something more
fitting like them slap shit until your
slap shit everybody which is again
something I'd much rather do they want a
DFS so to feel better they go to get a
tan from this sexy Oompa Loompa which of
course leads to even more confusing calm
Wow Wow
use me hmm oh sorry
I mean unexplained weird voice pervert
you'll never see again comic gold
apparently they thought that joke would
work so well that they actually do it
again only this time with a perverted
priest that's a mall or I'm Christmas
shopping of course you are
just leave me mind
notice that awkward silence that
accompanying this entire scene that's
because you're laughing so hard at this
ingenious setup that they're actually
allowing you to laugh at it don't
consider it that way loser others risky
um hey yes because tanning is not God's
Way or the way of all these onlookers
who clearly have never left their homes
and have no idea what's supposed to be
inappropriate in the real world hell it
even makes the front page of the news I
am NOT shitting you with the front page
news what the hell is going on here
they're preparing for Cruz according to
unnamed sources okay
I haven't been to Oak Park or Riverside
recently as they're not that far away
from me but this counts as front-page
news to them seriously stop the presses
everybody a rock oh my god this is the
biggest story ever since squirrel we're
I'm bigger this were locked out
everybody we have to address the
elephant in the room
that's right I forgot about those means
always try to force of course okay that
did connect to anything yes it is but
just like that my my was frozen
great
I thought all these repetitive
traditions would be great but I'm sorry
I got a return to effort what you can't
go back it why not because you're
supposed to learn your lesson by the end
of the video we're not even halfway
through look at the little red ball oh
there I don't care I need to go back
right now fine but we're violating the
screenwriting lessons of Chris Columbus
let's never have him in the house again
agreed
you out what have you done what your
reviews they have more variety actors
and visuals well yeah you guy you've all
been or to stay relevant
I see reviews where there wasn't even
one white wall that's your identity and
some of these don't even have clips from
the movie yeah it's a different kind
reviewing to get a lot of hits that's
not traditional how the hell can do a
review with no clips similar to a lot of
critics do it for hundreds of years no
it's not a review it's just sketches
you're not saying anything about the
movie at all makes no sense because we
yeah no commentary in the slightest who
knows what this might lead to crossovers
anniversary specials a pointless feud
with an angry gamer and all of them will
bomb okay I don't have time for this go
back to say Mac credit card twenty times
no I am not done here yet well I tried
so in an effort to make you as
uncomfortable as possible
this scene happens if she'll do it for a
check-up yesterday McCants respect third
time whoa this could be her last
thanks well okay I guess we have to find
the time to show how this is affecting
everybody or we can just return to the
goofy music installation an against it
is an old Scrooge himself I'm not even
kidding
it cuts directly to that after literally
20 seconds 20 seconds of suddenly
talking about cancer Jesus Christ the
bedside manner of this movie is on par
with a Canadian PSA it's a rape whistle
Merry Christmas
they even have the balls to cut to the
husband of the cancer patient being an
asshole again what is this movie trying
to do I try to be old man stop that
table stop calling me old man you're
like 10 years older than me am i yeah
well prove it Walt I just heard about
bad I'm so sorry
you know if we could bottle this movie
and drop it on our enemies nobody would
ever touch us so later on on the most
evenly lit block in town a bunch of
carolers come to sing for the holiday
this causes the cranes to duck-and-cover
for some reason bells on bobtails ring
making spirits bright what fun it is to
ride and sing a sleighing song tonight
Oh jingle bells jingle bell does this I
mean I'm not a fan of something like
country music that doesn't mean I'm
gonna act anything like this as somebody
played it Tamra stop playing that music
why just do it oh don't ever force me to
have those incredibly normal spasms
again okay can we never cut back to
Aykroyd singing again I thought there
was a legal agreement he would never do
that again after Blues Brothers 2000 Oh
apparently their Christmas spirit is so
down that even their statue of frosty
turns evil I can't make that shit up
and that's not just the lighting they
had to literally sculpt that to give it
an evil brow your symbolism is amazing
once you just have an alien pop up and
gravity and say she's a fetus it's a
metaphor for me this leads to the movie
turning into home alone for absolutely
no reason
yeah take that mailman who has no
interest in my actions look out it's
clearly not cold enough outside for that
water to freeze I'm just gonna assume
that was thrown in there for the poster
is it on there yeah animal cruelty is
fine as long as it's used for
promotional purposes and hey since it's
the early 2000s why not a needless Botox
joke I had a Botox injection today
because the Lord knows this won't be
everywhere they had a Botox the Botox I
just swung by the Botox party you bring
any Botox and you bring a bowl top did
you bug talk to your face into an
expressionless mask now Dom it's time we
lay that joke to rest don't do it after
his face heals literally the next day
hey heals faster than your stars this
movie leaves people call their house
demanding that they free frosty they
even start standing outside all day hey
Bobby you want to waste hours of our
childhood chanting outside a house about
how someone should hang up a piece of
plastic like girly boy hasn't but
suddenly to get news then not only is
their daughter coming home for Christmas
that night but she just met someone and
is getting married oh that seems really
fast and out of nowhere we should
obviously sit her down and talk about
her future havin a party or throw a
Christmas party that's obviously much
more important here what about our trip
this was all your stupid idea by Vince
ago I was a genius yeah well now you're
an idiot
hey that's what every fan said about
John Grisham after watching this movie
five minutes ago I was a genius yeah
well now you're an idiot
this moment is apparently so wonderful
that Frosty goes back to smiling again
it is that snowman possessed should we
make the next one out of holy water so
they always
Boy Scouts rake up the price for their
shittiest tree kinda surprised they
allow their name to be attached that is
actually so Alan asked his neighbor if
he can borrow his Christ that's not a
tree that's a stoners breakfast but it's
ok he uses one of the kids still
chanting outside his house to help him
out ok seriously who would waste so much
time on something so pathetic uh pretty
I never thought I say this but you have
my permission to beat the shit out of me
free Critic free critic wait a minute he
barely had you in this episode didn't he
that's true what if I told you I could
get you an even more important role
so curtis goes to pick up the last
Hickory honey ham in the store but
another woman has her sights on it okay
can we agree that any movie with comedic
Nutcracker music should be dead to the
world happy holidays you know I feel
like slap shit is too good a word for
this now
how about shit shit that's you just
watches what you say shit shit can you
think of any other perfect word for this
help a little kid can look at this and
be like shit yes yes very good daily
shit shit indeed seriously shall ever
sell it but she comes across what martin
sure will look like two years from now
who somehow gets invited to the party
thank you who are you
meanwhile Ellen tries to put frosty up
on the roof hey kids nice mr. crank is
putting up his frosty to hell with these
boring video games we can watch the
wonder of a man slowly plugging in a
light
okay is this thing made out of Satan's
saliva or no children
but emergency vehicles come pointlessly
parking on the lawn and cutting him down
in a way that injures him even more huh
fire fires bunch of hacks right so they
finally let everybody know that they're
celebrating Christmas again and they
need their help to get ready drop what
you're doing and pitch yet why should we
do this for him yeah sure
regardless of how you feel about Luther
I know a lot of you have mixed feelings
about him now but we're a community a
dangerously OCD community with issues
we'll address another time the people in
a community stick together even if one
of them has been behaving for most of
the holiday season like a spoiled
selfish little baby unlike us bottom
line
peer pressure always works if someone
doesn't do what you want harass them
until they do it Christmas so as
everyone tries to prepare for the party
a couple of cops who should be on duty
pick their daughter up all while
partaking and what I can only call
seizure-inducing editing option from I'm
here you read me Wow if that doesn't
give you a medical condition I don't
know what I'll just roll my hair in fact
is it me or is it repeating boy if that
really was repeating that could really
mess up your mind a little bit maybe
even causing you to pass
excellent now the Nastasha Creek will be
like the old days nothing but quits
memes if there's time and actual
analysis of the movies hahaha you'll
give us a more important role right of
course
you
No why is it whenever I wake up I always
have a 50/50 chance I'll be held against
my will
okay well special storage closet edition
we see one plug somehow takes out an
entire block but has turned right back
on again I alerts you if this ever
becomes relevant as the cops are told to
stall dropping off Blair because they're
not ready for the party
so they faked a break-in going on only
to discover there really is a break-in
going on what are the goddamn chances
there is please I was talking to that
ladybug on the ground as I clearly
didn't throw that anywhere near you
they eventually catch and arrest him
yeah guessing that was a fun ride home
as per obvious police protocol they
don't take him to the police station
drive him instead to a suburban home
abandon him and go inside to enjoy the
party leaving him all alone in the car
with the window open crisis they're
spilling it for how much stupid this
movie is doing and get this purposefully
overlooked malcolm in the middle' jaw
comes up to the criminal and actually
falls for the lie he's telling him I'm
starving out here I haven't eaten in
seven days seven days yeah any scraps I
get I give to the kids you look about
the age of idiot you believe anything I
say right no funny business right yeah
swear on my kids lives I mean come on if
you can't trust a guy in the back of a
police car who can you trust
thankfully this doesn't interrupt the
toast that our family is making I just
wanted to say thank you you really have
shown us the true meaning of community
through your constant harassment you
came through after we gave you exactly
what you wanted Cheers assholes but Alan
is mad because he didn't get to go on
his trip and also because this movie
clearly doesn't know how to stop why is
this still going everyone out there
sacrificed their Christmas Eve to help
us
I thought maybe that might affect you
maybe have you started thinking about
putting others first instead of yourself
why can't you join the rest of the
neighborhood in their one selfish need
but Alan gets the idea to go to the
neighbor whose wife has cancer how's
Beth she's having a good day yeah thanks
uh we started over to see Blair but you
know snow started yes and it was a whole
two more feet so seeing how Allan and
Curtis aren't going to use their tickets
anymore they decide to give it to the
couple allowing them to go on the trip
instead of them this is a sincere
heartfelt Christmas offering to two very
selfless people hmm yeah should we look
at those selfless moments again think
you can run away from Christmas huh he's
kind of weird it is an old Scrooge
himself thought they would have made you
a partner by not what uh sure real Saint
I got airline tickets like a cruise
passes I've got a brochure half of those
you can't transfer over as everybody
knows but hey if the last-minute thought
that counts
what about the cat I'll take the cat are
you sure yes because after stepping on
it hissing at it and freezing it nearly
to death I totally trust you to look
after his well-being by God remember the
days when scenes had one or two dumb
moments in it this has got to be a
Guinness record but even still it's not
over as the burglar decides to rub the
Kranks house as opposed to literally
every other empty house on the block no
what are you bringing a cot and we
finally find out who that guy was who
Curtis invited to the party I told you
you could use an umbrella wait a minute
either guy that was selling umbrellas in
the rain or it's a living what a twist
and incredibly weak tying in to
absolutely nothing important twist and
here it finally ends thank God
I can't imagine in the last few seconds
they possibly make this any dumber
okay I can't imagine it possibly getting
dumber than fat in the last pot
Merry Christmas to all and I spiked all
your eggnog what the hell was that
he was Santa who dresses as Santa
because he doesn't look like Santa it
flies a Volkswagen after selling
umbrellas for money
Santa sells umbrellas for money but he
has reindeer we at least got that part
right about him
you know seeing how we pretty much got
every other conceivable thing about him
wrong but hey at least Christmas with
the Kranks set us straight proving once
again that they have an unbelievable
understanding of everything Christmas
it's so stupid it's so stupid it's so
stupid that's this exploding problem
looked at and that was my eight-minute
review of the last airbender I'm sorry
the wall was the wrong color but hey at
least it's not as bad as how bad traffic
doc what the hell are you doing I did it
I did a traditional nostalgic rate
review with no visuals no cutaways just
me in front of a white wall what'd you
do with Malcolm and Tim oh I put them to
good use okay get the hell out of here
you're exactly like this movie you think
that never changing and just repeating
the same traditions over and over it
somehow what's most important well I'm
about to show you I just posted this on
the internet and I'm gonna prove that
people like to see the exact same
formula over and over and soon you're
gonna head to chained to that wall to an
off white to off-white yeah on the Bears
you were ever a part of me I'm gonna
wrap up this review telling the world
that haha here we go look barely
anybody's watching it nobody cares that
this is like one of the old reviews yeah
well there you go idiot and the comments
they're not positive at all gosh it's
almost like the majority of online
comments are usually negative
look you're still pretty new to this but
there's a saying that most of us know
yeah you never read the comments but
that's why I did it to make them laugh I
figure maybe if I can make them laugh I
can finally get them to like me that's
the whole reason I started doing this
hey loser where's patty man I was
thinking maybe if you weren't doing
anything this Friday night maybe we
could hang out here rose
I just thought this would change
everything you know
we're not who we were we change
sometimes for the better sometimes for
the worse but we all change movies like
this don't want us to change they try to
shame those who do things their own way
they act like the importance is in the
details and not in the overall message
this is a horrible thing to teach
especially when talking about Christmas
but we shouldn't be ashamed of our past
nor shall we glorify it it's like
anything there's positives and negatives
there's good moments in bad times and
there's bad moments in good times
because of this traditions can be hard
to figure out too sometimes we obsess
over things when we don't need to other
times we try something new when we
probably should have left good enough
alone but in between one foot in the
past and one the future lies what
matters most the choices we make now are
what always has and always will define
who we are so this Christmas when you're
remembering to be kind and understanding
of others remember to be kind and
understanding of yourself and those
moments you remember as being
embarrassing you may find are not only
the most precious moments but often the
most important and sometimes should be
looked at with more appreciation than
you think we're always going to get
angry at ourselves but as long as you
always try to learn and get better
you'll find it doesn't last that long
and trust me when I say you're
definitely worth the time I'm the
Nostalgia Critic this movie can suck
don't touch me you gave me a seizure you
barely put us in the review yeah he made
that a lot better
hey it's not easy being a table
conscious you know how hard it is to
bounce a camera on top of your head Oh
God
tamra pay left pad right Dutch angle
white balance okay this is his white and
his balance as it gets
you're fired fine not even matter what
sure
hey everybody Doug Walker here doing the
charity shout out and I have a funny
story for you while we were shooting
this review we were outside about to
shoot a scene with nostalgia critic and
Santa Christ and this car pulls up and
they pull ran to our parking spot and we
don't recognize the people and take it
out and we say can we help you and they
say uh Toys for Tots Toys for Tots
no no no we're not Toys for Tots looking
us like are you sure we said yeah we're
sure why would we know where Toys for
Tots are and they said well cuz you got
a guy dressed like Santa Claus they're
unrelated I mean so bizarrely enough
they were driving around looking for
Toys for Tots that we happen to come
outside with a guy dressed as Santa
Claus what are the chances and I took it
as a sign so the charity we are doing
this week is Toys for Tots a lot of you
have heard this charity before this is a
charity that gets toys to kids who are
not able to have toys this Christmas a
lot of people donate in December but for
next year it's good to know that they
actually start in October and November
as well the more toys they can get the
more kids can have these toys and these
are children that either come across
hard times or the parents come across
hard times and are unable to get gifts I
mean there are so many people out there
they're just going through such rough
patches right now and just are not able
to do something that every kid deserves
every kid deserves to have presents
around Christmastime and these are
people that make it happen it's of
course done by the Marine Corps but they
also have so many good sponsors behind
they have Disney they have Macy's they
have Toys R Us all these people try so
hard to raise awareness and you see that
poster everywhere of Santa with
Marine uniform in the closet and if you
even go to their YouTube channel Marine
Toys for Tots you'll see that so many
kids benefit from this and so many
celebrities get behind this as well and
it's just a good cause because every
little kid deserves presents on
Christmas and by donating toys or money
to this wonderful charity you can help
make that happen so whether it's
donating online or just driving around
until you see a guy dressed like Santa
please definitely take the time to look
into it buy a gift for a child less
fortunate and help them have a wonderful
holiday donate to Toys for Tots yes
Santa Christ approves
Oh